bedford was one of the original hot
spots for the delta variant with a
spring surge in cases
but they've fallen 40 per cent in the
last three weeks
to the relief of residents it'd be
better that the number of people
having vaccinations and going up all the
time
it's good that it's in bedford going
down but we just want
everywhere to just go back to normal
everyone should be doing their bit
really
away from each other as much as possible
analysis by sky news shows the tide is
also turning in
other towns that had high infection
rates like bolton
and blackburn younger age groups shown
here in light blue and yellow
led the upward surge in recent weeks but
infection rates are now starting to fall
behavior change may be one reason with a
six percent drop in people visiting
public spaces in blackburn and darwin
over the last two weeks of available
data but ramping up vaccinations
also helped with many more doses being
given in bolton and blackburn
compared to other areas to slow the
spread of the virus
the virus is increasingly coming up
against a wall of immunity as more of us
have had the vaccine or a previous
infection
with covid while cases are bubbling up
there aren't enough people
still vulnerable to the infection to
sustain the surge
the health secretary has said he's
encouraged by the latest data
with hospitalizations and deaths
remaining relatively low
this public health expert says even the
risk of long covid
is unlikely to sway the government from
relaxing lockdown
i personally think that the government
are heading for
herd immunity strategy without actually
naming it that
and at the same time they're aiming for
all over 18s to be vaccinated
and they're hoping that if you've got
healthy people who are getting the covet
infection they're not going to hopefully
end up in hospital and therefore death
rates will remain low
you come to your first fisa yeah okay
virologists who've tracked the virus
through two waves already
are increasingly hopeful this time round
cases are no longer rising exponentially
and this professor says they may even
level off this week
i'm a lot more optimistic and i'm quite
confident
that um we are going to have a much
better summer this year than we had last
year and i think
that is down to the really impressive
success we've had with the vaccines
if the abrupt downturning cases in the
hot spots is mirrored nationally
then the third wave may turn out to be
more of a ripple
rare good news in the long pandemic
thomas more sky news in bedford